carrie i have to tell you how much fun i
had listening to your new album denim
and rhinestones first of all fantastic
title um
you know it definitely had a bit of a
throwback vibe i was picking up some 80s
and some 90s vibes in the best way
possible what did you want to say with
this new music
i mean in the very beginning when we
started um you know
getting together to write um
my my co-producer said what do you want
what do you want to do
what are we doing this time
and i was like you know what i just want
to have fun um
after the the couple years that
everybody's had um you know i got to
make two
albums that i am so proud of um
our christmas album um my gift and then
my gospel album my savior um i feel like
those were very like deep soulful um
projects and and such a deep wonderful
place that i was in um but coming out of
that i was like let's think ahead what
do we want we want to take this on the
road like i'm ready to have some fun
let's do this let's have some fun
well you succeeded because it's one of
the first things i thought about when i
finished listening to your album i was
like that was so much fun
that was great and definitely perfect
music for going on tour you know when
you are creating new music for an album
do you listen to your own music over and
over again either in the car at home so
you get a feel for the album
um i listen to all of the things we have
steps along the way um and co-producing
i feel like you know i end up listening
to
myself way more than i would like to
i don't necessarily go back and listen
to other things that i've done in the
past but you know when when there's new
guitar parts or
we switch the drums out or whatever it
is like um i feel like i'm constantly
listening to um my my own stuff and it's
it's been a lot of fun too i also have
to learn everything right so that's true
important that's an important step um
but yeah i mean it's it's it's been a
lot of fun you know writing and
recording and um and being able to to
listen through everything and so i feel
like i've been living with this for a
while you know
release it into the world yeah your
baby's out there uh you know we know
that you're an amazing singer we know
that your husband mike is an amazing
hockey player maybe not the best singer
uh does that make him the best litmus
test is he the one that you go to for
honest opinions when it comes to your
new music no no
why
um
he will be
he will definitely be brutally honest
um but my my whole thing is like i
when i'm making music like i'm
doing what i love
um obviously you you want that to
translate to fans but he's not
he's not my fan you know what i mean
he's my husband and um there's stuff
that like i don't think he heard until i
was done
um because i i don't
in in so many contexts obviously i
value his opinion and his thoughts and
his feelings um in this context not so
much
and i don't mean that in a disrespectful
way yes it's probably really smart
i'm doing like he's not gonna come to me
for like
how man i had a terrible game like what
do i do in the next game you know what i
mean so and i'd be like i don't know
like you look good out on the ice like
look fine to me
uh so
yeah i i
i wouldn't give him that advice so i
don't necessarily
want
advice
i love mac but i don't want your
painting on my new music no i think
that's actually smart we listen to very
different kinds of music anyway um just
in our musical tastes so i don't know if
he would be a carrie underwood fan if he
was not married to oh
no wait what does he listen to
um i mean
it's not it's more what i listen to um
i love like super hard rock music yeah
um i love you know country music i love
the ladies of country music um
i'll just leave it at that we just
listen very different kinds of music i
love that are your kids at the point
where they're giving you honest feedback
or do they just love everything you you
do and when they listen to you sing
they're like we love you mom they'll
they'll never be like i don't like that
song yeah but it's it's fun to listen to
to you know they'll request things in
the car and sometimes they do request my
songs so
off this album um i think crazy angels
is probably isaiah's favorite
um and they also request denim and
rhinestones um sometimes as well i'm not
gonna lie those are my favorite i love
crazy angels i think it's so so good and
denim and rhinestones is just so much
fun i also love ghost story thank you
love that love the whole music video you
know the whole idea of you haunting past
lovers is just really fun and i know
you're happily married uh but you know
are there people in this world that you
know you are their ghost story
i mean i'm sure i'm sure we've all got
one you know i'm sure every single
person on this planet just has somebody
that kind of creeps into their memory
every once in a while and you're just
like where is that person what are they
doing like you know i should have done
this differently
whatever it is um i have not seen any of
the exes in a whole long time
uh because i have been married for
almost 12 years now yeah um but i'm i'm
sure and i like unfortunately when you
look at somebody who's you know like
become
um a celebrity yeah it would be kind of
hard to escape like any that i'm not
just saying me i'm saying any any of us
uh if you're on like magazine covers or
whatever you're like checking out the
grocery store and they're like there's
an ex-girlfriend again like on the cover
of whatever and uh that would be it
would be difficult i just want to watch
some football why is my friend singing
the opening like what's happening
it's true i think about that because you
can't just block someone on social media
it's not enough if you're a celebrity
and you're everywhere
right i mean i've moved to nashville so
i'm far away from everybody but still
yeah exactly
you